well good morning everybody and welcome
to the mid-south district council
licensing and regulatory committee third
of december 2021
my name is
kathy guthrie and i'm the chairman of
the licensing and regulatory committee
and i'll be chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
you maintain social distance from all
other persons whilst in the chamber and
the communal areas please ensure that
you wear a face covering at all times
unless you are seated or if you're
exempt from doing so and that you use
the hand sanitizers and wipes provided
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair and please do not
interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use and please
ensure mobile phones are on silent or
switched off
additionally we'll be using e-voting on
the modern gov app for this meeting so
could members ensure that they are
logged in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except whether
our confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting
as a speaker you are also consenting to
being recorded by the council and the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
so we move on to the agenda um first of
all i'll make introductions
we have nigel de liu our legal officer
over there
we have kay sanders our licensing
officer
kerry chandler our licensing officer
karen sayer our governance officer
and bethany
over there trainee governance officer
can we move to the agenda please
apologies for absence
thank you chair we've received apologies
from councillor epeng young councillor
flatman councillor muller and councillor
otton
thank you
declarations of interest by councillors
none
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 15th of october 2021 are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the minutes
no
thank you can i have a proposal
thank you councillor geek and a
secondary councillor brewster thank you
so may we go to an electronic vote
please thank you
thank you chair the um the vote for the
uh this item should now be open in the
app if you click on the plus sign in the
top right of the agenda screen please
and that's three votes four chairs that
vote is carried
thank you for that and whilst at this
point um i would just like to say that
we are correct although we are a bit
short in members through sickness so
just for the record please
that we
are correct
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received chair
did we have any questions by councillors
none received
mlr 21.9 gambling act 2005 statement of
principles statutory three-year revision
so i now invite
the licensing officer k to introduce the
report to the committee please thank you
thank you chair
this report is to report back to the
licensing and regulatory committee the
outcome of a full targeted and public
reconsultation this is to include the no
casino resolution
the consultation ran between the 18th of
october 2021 and the 14th of november
2021 in respect to the statutory policy
revision relating to the gambling act
2005 functions
this report seeks the approval of the
licensing and regulatory committee of
the revised principal statement which is
now attached as appendix a for
recommendation onto full council so that
they make so it may be adopted for
publication and ready to take effect
from 31st january 2022.
the recommendations are that the full
post-consultation draft statement of
principles in respect of the gambling
act 2005 functions as attached as
appendix be approved and that the
committee make recommendation to full
council that the statement of principles
document be adopted this is a statutory
requirement to review and re-adopt the
council's gambling policy
a summary of the changes made brought to
this committee on the 15th of october
2021 from the 2019 statement to redraft
is attached to this report as appendix b
this will be the sixth edition of the
statement of principles once approved
and adopted it should take effect for a
three-year period from the 31st of
january 2022 although it may be revised
sooner if necessary it will become a
primary point of reference for
councillors officers applicants and
other responsible interested parties
following the second consultation mid
suffolk received no responses
i just need to point out i believe it's
on page 18 of your papers in in the
statement um 2.4 the date will be
inserted after full council meeting on
the 27th of january
thank you chair
thank you for that
um so i can now open it up for debate
i'm sure um
both of you would like to give your
views please who would like to go first
counselor geek may i suggest you
might want to say something
thank you chair um i'd just like uh as
always with the licensing committee to
thank the officers very much and
particularly for how clearly it's laid
out and how easy it is for us to
understand and grasp and
and just say that i i will be voting for
this um and thank you very much for all
you've done
thank you for that councillor geek
councillor brewster
it's it's it's a good document and and
worth 34. so i should be voting for it
and thank you
i would just like to say thank you to
the team as well because of course this
went out in the first instance and had
to be reissued and the time scale that
they had to do it
and the speed in which the team had put
their back into it so thank you very
much indeed and we do have a short time
scale to get it through at the next full
council four days to spare i believe
um so well done to them and as you all
say a very clear document
so thank you so with that
um can we
have a proposal and a second of please
counselor geek
thank you chair i would like to propose
that we accept the document as it stands
thank you
and councillor brewster was second thank
you very much so if we can go to the
vote that would be very helpful thank
you very much
thank you chair if you could um please
now open this boat in the modern.gov app
by clicking on the plus sign thank you
foreign
[Applause]
that's three votes for again chair
that's carried
well thank you very much indeed
so i think now we can close the meeting
thank you for everyone's attendance
thank you